Welcome back, trust you enjoyed the animation and it gave you an overview of this model.
Now we're going to take a deep dive, look into it and unpack it together and explore
how this can apply in our personal lives and in our working lives.
So as you see on the screen here, we have this model in more detail.
It's visually displayed here.
Again, we've got some athlete examples.
However, this of course is going to be applied to our own lives in our own unique ways.
So of course it's going to apply to you in how it makes sense to you.
So let's explore.
So above the line is when we, before we even explore above the line,
we are moving above or below the line like the animation showed,
depending on the pressure in the situations that we're going through in life.
When everything's sunshine, everything's easy and everything's flowing,
it's naturally a lot easier to stay above the line.
But it's all about when we have pressure.
Now you probably heard the saying pressure makes diamonds.
Well, when we have pressure, how we respond changes our life.
And it either helps us grow and flow or diminish and contract.
Now naturally we all want to grow.
So let's unpack this.
When there's pressure, are you going above the line or are you dropping below the line?
So when you're going above the line, you're taking responsibility.
You're taking personal responsibility for what happened.
I messed this up.
I made this mistake.
So if we explore that in a working scenario, I crashed this, I dropped the plate.
I did this, it's on me.
I take responsibility for that.
People who do that, other people see that and they respect them straight away.
Why?
Because they're not hiding.
They're a leader.
So when you have that response, you're willing to, it's got a little mirror icon there,
you're willing to be real with yourself, to look at yourself and go,
yep, I did that.
It's on me.
That is so attractive as a leader.
So attractive.
People will be admiring that and more importantly, they can trust that.
Next thing is that when there's a difficulty, you're willing to take action.
Some people procrastinate.
So if we go to the opposite of taking action, we've got the little ostrich which is head
in the sand there and they're procrastinating.
It's because they're feeling emotions.
It could be fear.
It could be apprehension and they're like, I don't know what to do.
Now, you might not be able to take action directly.
So that's why you can ask for feedback so that you also see on the screen there,
feedback is above the line.
So what does that mean?
What does that look like?
Well, it could be asking your wife or your husband for some advice.
It could be asking someone in your team what to do.
If you're feeling blocked or stuck, you ask for feedback.
It's super, super important.
You can ask like AI, you could ask people that may know, you may do a Google search
or however it is, you're looking for ways to move, to take action, to find solutions.
So we've also got there with the little white light bulb, finding solutions.
You're also exploring different choices.
So you feel that I've got options here.
It's not like only this particular way.
There are options.
There's ways to solve this problem.
I'm going to, again, look for feedback.
I'm going to come up with solutions.
I'm taking responsibility and you're responding instead of reacting.
So there's a big difference there.
Let's go below the line and look at some of the typical things that we would do.
So a lot of times when we feel internal pressure, it doesn't feel nice.
So we want to release that pressure.
We want to get rid of that pressure internally so we blame other people.
It's a really cheap, easy way to do it.
It was your fault.
It's not me.
We're moving the pressure away from us that does not make us a leader.
It makes us a victim.
So victim is, I've all heeded this to me and they did this and it's everyone else's fault,
blaming excuses of victim.
They normally work together.
They dance together and we judge other people.
They're not doing their role right.
Now there is a time to make a judgment.
There is a time to give feedback, but it's in what spirit are you doing it?
Then of course underneath these feelings, there's often fear.
And again, these are natural things to feel.
We're not saying that you shouldn't feel fear or you shouldn't feel emotional tension.
That's why in the middle, we've got the words letting go and acceptance.
Letting go and acceptance.
So you're not judging what you're feeling.
You're not judging what you're experiencing because, hey, what's your feelings?
What's your feeling?
Right?
You can't change that.
And this is where my research with a lot of the world champion athletes where they're
at now is they just accept what they're feeling and they just let go of it and then they move
on.
And so you're not, when you do that, you're not fighting against yourself.
You're not fighting against these difficult emotions because that's why people drop below
the line because they can't get rid of these yucky feelings and they're just desperate
to get rid of the feelings.
So they'll blame their excuses, judge others, feel hopeless, procrastinate, only see the
problems and they may even feel shame.
And all these emotions drop you below the line.
They block progress.
They block progress in your personal life and in your working life as well.
So we want to get above the line naturally as much as we can.
So this model gives us that awareness, understand that every single person drops below the line
at times.
It's normal.
We're human, but we don't stay there.
We're conscious.
Oh my gosh, I'm doing it.
I'm blaming me.
Excuse us.
I'm judging.
Oh my gosh, I'm procrastinating.
Okay.
What do I do because we can get stuck when we're down there?
Well this fantastic model helps us become aware below the line.
So in Jabaraj's case, the school teacher in Nepal, you can imagine an earthquake just
destroys your village.
My gosh, could you imagine what's going on there?
His wife, he said to me, his wife was below the line.
You can have compassion.
You can understand why she would.
She's probably feeling like a victim.
There's terrible things happened.
She's maybe blaming the government for not helping enough, probably blaming Jabara, blaming
God.
Who knows what you're doing?
Probably in fear, feeling hopeless and nervous and just stuck frozen in this state or below
the line.
Because Jabaraj was aware of this model, according to him and the feedback he gave me, he knew
that he couldn't stay in those emotions because it's going to be terrible.
So he went looking for solutions, taking responsibility, being the hero for his family and for his village.
Responding, looking for solutions, taking actions.
And he got through it.
And I came back and they were having actually a new home being developed and the funding
was eventually released.
But during that uncertainty period, he chose and it's a choice.
He also got choice above the line to take that action to be above the line.
And that gives you personal power to be able to do that.
So now imagine this in how this plays out in your personal life and in your working
life.
Imagine the difference between being with people in your team or around you who are
always below the line versus those that choose to be above the line.
Just the complete comparison is massive.
Now again, remembering this is not about learning this model and then being judgmental to yourself
like, oh, I need to be above the line all the time.
Yes, it's great to be there.
And of course we want to do that.
But just notice when you dip, ah, that's what I'm doing.
Now let me go back above the line and you're really gentle with yourself.
That's why in the middle of this model, and this is something that I developed when I
first learned this, I added this part on that wasn't initially there, is its acceptance
and letting go is so important.
You accept, I just dropped.
Okay, I've just done, I just blamed.
Oh my God, I just did this.
All right, I've done it.
I'm now taking responsibility.
I'm now going on to take action.
And where we've got the word meaning there, that's about finding purpose and meaning in
the difficulties.
It's finding meaning.
And that is a choice.
Now some extreme examples of this is what I studied, people that survived the concentration
camps of Archwich.
And there's a fantastic book called Man's Search for Meaning by Viktor Frankl.
And he talks about the importance between stimulus when something happens and our response.
So something's happened and our response, there's a space between that and we can fill
it up with purpose and meaning.
And this is a very attractive quality to cultivate.
And it's what he believes and he attributes that helped him survive the most, one of the
most incredibly difficult things a human can go through.
And that's finding meaning.
And ultimately when you do all those things and you're above the line more, you're going
to have the results in your life and your personal life and obviously in your working
life.
So that's the above the line, below the line model.
I trust you've enjoyed it and I look forward to seeing you in the next sections.